Hello friends, this is Jeff with Ability
Lock and Key. I am here to make an extra
key for a 2011 [music]
Honda Fit. Now I'm going to generate an
XHorse key. And to do that, we're going
to go to
we're going to go to frequency
detection.
And I'm going to take the original key
first. And I'm I'm using this right
here. I'm hold key down here.
Okay, we got 313 MGHertz FSK.
So, with that information,
we will
we'll go back and we'll hit vehicle
remote and we'll go to
Honda
and we'll select fit to kind of uh
minimize what's out there. And then
we're going to look for three. Okay,
there's our FSK.
Okay, 313. Oh, that's Australia. Wrong
one. Okay, let's go a little further
down. Here we are. 313 FSK.
We're going to hit that right there. And
then I'm going to take
and put
third key in my pocket momentarily. I'm
going stick this in right here. Okay.
I'm going to hit generate.
Uh-oh. Can't find any key. You can't?
Well, I'm here. Let's just try that
again.
Oh, anyway, so it shouldn't really
matter.
No, it's not. There we go. Focused.
So much shadow on it, but that's okay.
We hit complete. try to do here is I'm
going to take not my forward key.
Uh let's do this. Go back.
Back. We're going to do transponder
clone. We're going to stick their key
in.
And we're going to hit read transponder.
Okay. We're going to hit clone.
Start clone. 46 transponder clone
check and key.
Okay, it says to take that out,
but this Oh, you know what? I don't
think this is going to work cuz I'm
trying to do it with a uh
>> remote head key.
>> I'm using a new Yeah, it needed the
super remote and I've already made this
one up. We're just going to go to the
vehicle. We got to cut this key first
and then we'll go to the vehicle and
program it in. So hold tight them in.
Okay. So here we're going to decode the
key and then I'll just show you a little
trick at the end of doing that uh so
that we know whether it's a valid code
or not.
Well, if it's on like it was with the
last one, it won't show a valid code.
This is a 2011 Honda 2, so it may have
it right, it may not. You never know.
this machine. I mean,
>> yeah,
[bell]
>> learn. Okay, we have learn key success
over here.
>> Over here.
>> Oh,
>> okay.
>> I'm so sorry. Okay,
>> we'll hit okay. All right. One thing I
always check is the very last numbers
need to be ones. Okay. At this point,
this is what it read. Now, we're going
to hit find bidding
and see what comes up. There's a valid
key code. So, we're going to cut a
keyblade based on that. We feel
confident that that's right. I feel
confident that that's right. And uh and
then we'll go to the car and program it
in.
[bell]
>> [bell]
>> Okay, we're inside our Honda Fit. We've
got our X100 Pro hooked up again. We're
going to select key. key. Now, we
already got the customer's key, so we're
going to hit key, enter, add a key,
initializing communication,
switch ignition off.
Let's turn it on with the original key.
Turn it off. Now, it's going to ask for
the new key. Turn it on with the new
key.
Okay. Turn it off.
Turn it on.
Turn it off. Turn it on.
Is a light off? Best I can tell. I
wasn't actually looking for it. So,
we'll hit enter. Switch off.
Now, it's going to ask for the original
key. And I've got to pull this one out.
>> Oh, no. I thought their ignition switch
going on bad.
>> No, no, no, no. It was just
>> You haven't got it rolling.
>> Okay, here we go. Okay,
>> turning it on with the original key.
Okay, here we go. Key registration
completed. So, let's take the Let's go
on and start it with this one.
Starts with the original, which that
shouldn't have changed. Now, we'll try
to start it with this one.
Well,
>> he's going to have to do something. I
don't know what he's
>> I should actually have
What I should have done was uh
Okay,
put the roll pin in, but always wait to
do that just in case we can't get a
remote to work. Okay, so there it's
cranked with the exhorse key. Now, let's
check the remote
and the remote is not working.
So, we'll have
>> Okay. So, just took a a minute to
recognize it. You know, computer to
reset or whatever you pay attention.
This is the original. The original's
working now. We'll take Oops.
Tuck that in my leg there. We'll take
the Xorse and we'll do unlock lock. It's
working. And then just again to show you
that the vehicle cranks
cranks and runs. So, we're all done
here. Appreciate y'all watching. Don't
forget to like and subscribe. Remember,
you can't change the past, so live for
today and plan for tomorrow.